-i don't know if you know this,
but we're in the middle
of a Céline-issance.
-you should have let me know.
I would have dressed
appropriately.
-some magazine said that it's
the rebirth of Céline Dion.
We're in a Céline-issance.
And I go, "I love that."
-it's kind of nice.
Well, I feel like I'm being born
every morning.
-yeah. When you wake up.
Thank you.
-every day.
-i thought it maybe started
with your dress
from the met gala last year,
which I have to show.
It broke the Internet.
-what?
Did I break the Internet?
-yes.
-good. No I'm joking.
[ Laughter ]
-look at this dress.
Ooh, la, la.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that dress.
Stunning.
Is that what you just wear
normally around the house?
That's what I think.
-I go to bed like this at night.
-Absolutely. Yeah.
I actually asked you
for something that you do wear
in the house
walking around the house.
We asked your publicist.
-They gave you a picture
without my permission?
That's nice.
-Yeah.
This is you around the home.
This is what you wear.
There you go. That's Céline Dion
around the house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, listen.
-It's gorgeous.
-Well, you know,
I got to keep myself safe,
especially when I do scrambled
eggs in the morning
for the kids, you know?
-So, you coat yourself
in an armor.
Congrats on the residency
in Las Vegas --
The longest,
most successful residency
in the history of Las Vegas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's amazing.
-Thank you to all the fans
for coming.
That's kind of a game changer,
kind of a life changer.
'Cause you're like, "Yeah,
I guess I just live here."
It's like 16 years or something?
-I've been there for...17 years
living in Vegas. Yeah.
-Wow.
-Yeah, I was supposed to
be there for three months.
I don't know what happened.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what happens in Vegas.
-And what happens in Vegas,
stays in Vegas.
-No problem. I got you.
Céline, I always try to ask you
a good "Titanic" question
every time you're here because
I know you probably love those.
-You know that's a long time
ago, right?
-I know you love
those questions, yeah.
No, but here's
what everyone is saying,
and this is still being talked
about on the Internet,
on the interwebs.
They're saying at the end
of the movie,
if Rose just scooted over
a little bit,
just a little bit
just over here,
she could have saved
Jack's life.
Do you agree with this?
-Don't put me in trouble.
-No, come on!
America needs to know!
-What If they want to do
a "Titanic" number two?
-No! No, you can't do a
"Titanic" number two!
-No It's true.
-No, you can't.
-Listen, first of all --
First of all, if you look
closely to the picture,
Rose is maybe dead
or totally frozen,
and she's not quite
all there, okay?
Second of all,
he doesn't need an invitation.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Come on, baby!
Make yourself comfortable.
Jump in. You know?
-He could have pushed her over
a little bit.
-And then who did not think
about this guy who is
in the middle
of the frozen ocean
and that maybe all his body is
so frozen that he didn't have
the strength to...
♪ Jump in for my love ♪
-You didn't think that he could
♪ jump ♪
♪ For her love ♪
-♪ Jump in feel the touch ♪
♪ Jump in the water,
my kiss is in the night ♪
♪ Jump for my love ♪
Yeah, okay.
[Cheers and applause]
Come on. We love you.
A little more.
You're the best.
-You're so sweet.
We get to be silly on the show,
but let's talk about
your new album.
It is out today.
It is out right now.
Download it.
Go to Spotify.
Stream it.
It is called "Courage," and
it's a great album cover there.
Why did you call it "Courage?"
-I called it "Courage"
because the last three years,
my family, myself, my kids,
my family,
went through tough times.
A lot of people go
through tough times.
And I really wanted to,
after the passing of Rene,
wanted to --
This is actually the first --
My first album in English
without him physically,
but he is always,
always within me,
and when this song came,
that was called "Courage,"
it represented all the album
because it was hard.
It was difficult.
And, also, it's a message that,
you know, courage is
such an important and big word
that all of us have courage.
And all of us at one point
in our lives know that we want
to use it, but, eventually,
sometimes, we might need it.
And we need that in our lives
to be able to hold on to,
to be able to find
our inner strength
and be really saying that,
"You know what?
I'm a mother.
I got my children.
I love to sing.
It's great,
and it's going to be okay.
And courage,
don't you dare fail me now."
-Yeah.
-You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I Love that.
You're doing the "Courage"
world tour right now,
and I heard this may be
a rumor, as well.
This is almost like another --
-Everything.
Oh, you're laughing. I see.
-No, I just heard
a rumor that --
No, I don't have a picture,
but I heard that you have
been known to drive --
-I don't even want to look
behind the desk.
-No. No.
I don't have a photo.
I heard you were maybe driving
your own tour bus.
-Oh, of course I do.
I don't normally drive
my own tour bus.
I drive my people crazy, too.
-[ Laughs ]
But you do that, and I heard
that you don't have a cellphone.
Is that true?
-Well, driving and texting at
the same time --
-Oh, that's true.
-The kid is thinking.
-But I heard that you're getting
into a laptop,
you're getting a cellphone,
and I thought it would be kind
of fun if me and you
took your first selfie.
[ Audience "awws" ]
Would you like to?
Do you know what a selfie is?
[ Laughter ]
-Why would I take a selfie?
-No, 'cause [imitating Dion]
you have to take a selfie.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone takes a selfie.
-I can try.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, no problem.
A selfie of us. I will
take care of you, I promise.
Ready? Hold on.
-Where do I look?
Where do I look?! Because I
don't want to have crooked eyes.
Where's the camera?!
Where's the camera, Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
All right, let me just show
everyone what we did.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-You see? But where do you look?
-It's perfect! It's perfect!
Céline Dion, everybody!